I think one of the biggest problems that
we face in our society and our day and
age,
neurodegeneration,
whatever you want to consider it,
is we really try to hide the truth from
people.
We've grown up in this world where
everything is fair.
Everybody gets a trophy.
Nobody's left behind.
Nobody is different.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm all for being equal,
treating people equally,
but the thing is,
as humans,
we are different.
We see things differently.
We feel things differently sometimes.
Although we can relate to other people,
we are not all the same as human beings.
We take losses and I think in today's
world where we grow up and it's more
normal to not let somebody understand
that they took a loss is really
negative.
It creates room for people to start
making excuses,
gives a reason for people to start
pointing the finger and other directions
for not taking responsibility for
themselves.
At the end of the day,
if you're not happy where you are,
it's your problem.
The circumstances,
it could be different compared to other
people.
Uh,
you could have definitely been dealt a
shitty hand.
Trust me,
I understand my life isn't perfect.
It's never gonna be perfect,
it's never been perfect,
but at the end of the day I had full
control over my situation.
If you're not happy with where you are,
if you're not happy with what you're
doing,
it's pretty fucking simple.
Stopped doing it.
We ensure,
yeah,
it gets scary.
It gets challenging and risky and you
never know what's gonna happen,
but at the end of the day,
isn't that why we are alive to
experience this opportunity that we're
given and not just sit by and watch it
go to waste overall your goals,
your ambitions and your objectives are
yours,
but so is the outcome and the process.
If you want it to happen,
you can make it happen.
If you don't,
you won't.
To stop blaming other people for your
fault.
Be honest with yourself.
Two thousand and 17,
if you know me by now,
I'm not somebody that's all about like
new year new me,
but one of the things that's easily able
to look at is just what you've done in a
previous year.
A lot of situations and a lot of people
just kind of look at a new year as an
opportunity to say,
okay,
these are the things I didn't do
correctly this year and is now moving
into the next year.
I'm going to do the things that are
going to make me better,
but 2017,
man,
I'm a big year for all of us.
The world.
Honestly,
so many crazy things happened this year
with social media being with everybody
nowadays.
It was so easy to see all the terrible
that went on this year.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes it's nice to just kind of take
a second and remember all the good
things that actually happened in the
year.
I know for myself,
I was able to express what I love doing
for living in a way that brought me into
a new creative field,
this videography photography stuff.
My passion for my work as a freelance
designer helped influence me this year
to start stepping out of the comfort
zone,
I guess with other things
handed to that led me to this extremely
costly addiction in the video world,
which is.
It's awesome because I get to document
these moments,
hopefully years to come.
We'll be able to look back on this video
recapping 2017 and be like,
man,
2017,
good year,
you know,
all the way from just traveling more
this year,
living a little bit,
experiencing life to proposing to
Meghan.
Thank God she said yes by the way,
down to all the people that I got to
meet this year and hopefully influence
to chase after the things that they want
to do as well.
No,
a
lot of you guys that I've met this year
are amazing people.
You truly are the positivity,
the interaction that you guys bring your
way to special and creative to to not
push forward in 2018.
Please push forward in 2018.
You guys are amazing and this also goes
to all the people that I haven't met
yet.
There's tons of people out there with
the creative imagination and an a desire
to do something that they want to do and
they hold themselves back from doing it
or they wait till the next year to try
to do it.
Just do it now,
guys.
I want to take the opportunity to remind
the people and some of the positive
things that the youtube creators have
done this year.
Oh,
the fundraising that's gone on during
the drought for example,
or people losing loved ones,
taking the opportunity to use their fan
base to actually give back.
How amazing is that that we're in a
world now where people have the
opportunity to create their own content,
benefit from it,
and then also give back to the world
from it.
That's mindblowing.
We've definitely lost some amazing
people this year,
some amazing musicians,
at least on my end,
to musicians that really inspired me
throughout the years to just be the
person that I am today,
but even with losing them a gave us
opportunity to remember a lot of the
music.
Remember a lot of those old feelings
that drove us to create the path that we
created today.
If you look back at every single year as
a marketing point of what's happened in
your life,
it's going to have ups and downs.
Guys,
for some of you,
2017 wasn't a great year.
If bad things happen,
maybe you lost a loved one and I'm
truly,
truly sorry.
If you could find any part of you to
just look at the good things that did
happen this year and just focus on those
things.
Even if it's the littlest stuff to just
help push forward.
I promise you things will turn around.
Looking back throughout multiple years
have been at many low points to I've.
I've lost people.
I've had bad times.
I've been through depression and stress
and just felt so alone.
I can honestly say I've made the best of
2017.
It's had ups and downs,
but during those downtimes are focused
on a lot of the positive that I have
focused on a lot of the hard work that I
could put in and I did it here.
In a few weeks.
I'm going to be creating a short film of
kind of like an anniversary of me
quitting my job to be a freelance
designer.
I look forward to doing this video
because I did one last year and it's
just going to be insane.
Seen that transition of how I created
content.
Then to now,
if I actually remember correctly,
my first ever short film was the I quit
my job to be a freelance designer.
It's really cold out here.
It's so cold out here.
You guys are better appreciate this
video in some way,
shape or form because of freezing my ass
off to be out here and get this,
but it's so worth it because this is
where a lot of this type of stuff
started for me.
This documenting this,
getting out and doing stuff
in two days it's 2018 and I'm going to
head into 2018.
Not Remembering how great of a year 2017
was for me.
Not remembering the bad things that
happened in 2017,
but just realizing that no matter what
year it is,
as long as I'm still here,
I had the opportunity to live and I want
to take advantage of that to the best of
my ability.
I want to thank everybody who's been a
part of this year all the way down to
the coworkers,
that creative grenade,
all the customers that we've had this
year,
all the supporters and the videos and
the live streams,
Meghan,
family friends,
anybody that's just been a positive
influence in this year and that's been a
negative influence as well.
Thank you for pissing me off so much
so that way I gave the opportunity to
prove you guys
take every opportunity you guys get to
make something of it because we never
know what year is going to be.
Our last
is 2018.